bien Monsieur l'Ambassadeur nous sommes
particulièrement heureux de vous
accueillir pour la première fois ici et
en effet l'ambassadeur Lucas qui
représente je rappelle depuis 2
septembre 2020 la République fédérale
d'Allemagne nous avions déjà du resto
Disney déjà une fois ici
selon vous savez quel prix la France
attache à notre relation bilatérale avec
l'Allemagne et notre commission souhaite
du reste relancer les échanges avec les
parlementaires allemands vous aurez
confirmé ce point dans un instant je
rappelle malheureusement que l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande créée par
le traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle a été conçu
en excluant le Sénat ce qui nous a
beaucoup choqué c'est qui est
préjudiciable à la qualité de nos
relations inter parlementaires le Sénat
avait pourtant attiré à plusieurs
reprises l'attention de l'exécutif
français sur ce point alors nous savons
qu'il y a entre le
bundeslak Bundes strat il y a des
différences de compétences qu'il n'y a
pas en France mais enfin c'est un point
qui ne nous aide pas pour travailler
avec nos collègues c'est pour ça que
nous allons prendre des initiatives dans
cette maison pour débuter par
l'actualité Monsieur l'Ambassadeur la
Commission va être particulièrement
heureuse de vous entendre au sujet des
plus récents développement qui concerne
l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine et d'une
manière générale l'analyse que en
Allemagne fait sur la situation en
Ukraine l'ensemble des pays membres de
l'Union européenne ont démontré leur
détermination et leur unité en armant
les forces ukrainiennes depuis
l'agression russe du 24 février
jour anniversaire que nous allons hélas
prochainement célébrer tristement le 25
janvier dernier le chancelier fédéral
all of scholls a annoncé devant le
Bundes stars et sa décision de livrer à
l'Ukraine une compagnie de 14 chars
lourds léopard 2 de modèles A26 en plus
de ces véhicules prélevés sur les
équipements de l'armée allemande
cette décision ouvre la voie à la
livraison de Charles léopard détenu par
plusieurs autres pays occidentaux
notamment la Finlande et l'Espagne
la Pologne a ainsi annoncé la livraison
à Kiev de 14 chars léopard 2 de
fabrication allemande s'est engagement
exemplaire de l'Allemagne est intervenu
en concertation avec les partenaires
européens avec les États-Unis qui
simultanément ont annoncé la livraison à
l'Ukraine de 31 Chartres d'assaut de la
catégorie Abrams
alors que la guerre d'agression menée
par la Russie en Ukraine depuis 2022
dure depuis près d'un an vous nous
donnerez donc l'analyse du gouvernement
allemand sur les priorités de l'Union
européenne pour soutenir la résistance
ukrainienne
je crois que nous partageons tous le
sentiment sur lequel l'Ukraine doit en
effet gagner cette guerre et l'Allemagne
comme la France porte une responsabilité
historique pour que nos pays soient à la
hauteur de la dégradation actuelle de la
sécurité sur notre continent Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur vous êtes vous-même un des
meilleurs connaisseurs de la Russie nous
sommes donc particulièrement intéressés
d'avoir votre analyse sur les raisons
pour lesquelles nos pays ont échoué à
comprendre les projets de Vladimir
Poutine et sa volonté sa volonté de
lancer une guerre aussi brutale que
insensée comme à l'époque de la guerre
froide le décryptage des arcanes du
pouvoir russe est toujours difficile et
nous serons donc preneurs de votre
analyse sur ce qui pourrait être la
suite des événements en Russie
plus largement notre commission a suivi
avec attention les nombreuses annonces
faites par votre gouvernement dans le
domaine de la sécurité et de la défense
depuis un an
dans un important discours prononcé
trois jours après le déclenchement de la
guerre le chancelier schols a annoncé un
iTunes venden c'est-à-dire un changement
d'époque pour la politique extérieure
allemande dans le même discours il a
annoncé la création d'un fond spécial de
100 milliards d'euros pour moderniser la
Bundes verts avec le recul dont nous
disposons vous nous direz quelle réforme
et qu'elle réorientation ont été
engagées dans les forces allemandes
depuis ces annonces structurantes en
deuxième lieu nous serions heureux
d'évoquer avec vous les nombreux sujets
relatifs à la coopération bilatérale
entre nos deux pays le mois dernier les
nombreuses manifestations organisées
pour célébrer le 60e anniversaire du
Traité de l'Elysée 22 janvier 1963 entre
le général de Gaulle et le chancelier
Adenauer tout ceci a témoigner de la
vitalité de notre amitié
pour ceux qui concerne la défense et les
affaires étrangères nous le savons tous
l'Allemagne est un partenaire
stratégique essentiel de nos forces
armées et la poursuite de cette
coopération est une condition majeure à
l'établissement de l'autonomie
stratégique de notre continent et donc
nous serons heureux d'entendre votre
analyse au sujet des principales
coopérations entre nos deux pays dans le
domaine capacitaire notre commission
s'est publiquement félicité de l'avancée
réalisée en décembre dernier pour le
lancement de la phase de démonstrateur
pour le projet de SCAF le système de
combat aérien du futur
parallèlement vous nous direz quels sont
les perspectives d'avancement pour un
second projet structurant de notre
coopération bilatérale le char du futur
on croyait qu'on aurait plus besoin de
ça et bien malheureusement l'actualité
le démontre différemment
le fameux Shark que l'on désigne sous le
nom technique de système de combat
terrestre principal et CTP ou mgcs en
anglais alors avant de vous céder la
parole j'aimerais aussi évoquer d'un
moulé les perspectives d'évolution
institutionnelle de l'Europe de l'Union
européenne en effet le tandem
franco-allemand joue depuis l'origine un
rôle moteur pour façonner le périmètre
de compétences et les règles de
fonctionnement de notre Union européenne
on ne peut que se féliciter de la
nomination récente de la désignation
d'un groupe d'experts binational
franco-allemand qui permettra de
formuler des propositions communes pour
adapter les institutions de l'Union aux
enjeux du monde actuel sur l'ambassadeur
vous avez la parole pour une
présentation puis après nous ouvrirons
le dialogue avec vous ainsi que nos
collègues l'ambassadeur vous avez la
parole
je rappelle que cette audition est
captée
la possibilité de d'échanger avec vous
sur les relations font quoi allemande
les sénatrices monsieur le sénateurs
peut-être avant venir au sujet de
l'Ukraine peut-être en mots sur
sur le récent conseil ministre
franco-allemand et sur les célébrations
à l'occasion du 60 d'anniversaires du
traité riche je pense que c'était en
signal très très fort de l'unité
franco-allemande
en signal très fort aussi de en
témoignage n'est-ce pas de notre
ambition partagée de renforcer l'Europe
dans un temps des crises multiples pas
seulement la guerre en Ukraine mais
c'est le changement climatique c'est la
crise énergétique c'est l'inflation donc
ce sont beaucoup des crises auxquelles
nous faisons face et là le couple
franco-allemand le tandem ou le moteur
font également joué un rôle tout à fait
en essentiel et je pense que le 22
janvier c'était vraiment une
démonstration tout à fait
impressionnante notre volonté commune de
faire face à ces défis là y compris y
compris sur le sujet de l'Ukraine et
peut-être je commence mon intervention
avec quelques Mac là-dessus donc pour
nous tous l'invasion russe en Ukraine
c'était c'est un choc c'était le retour
de la guerre sur le sur le sol européen
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
chancelier Scholl c'est en son discours
vous l'avez mentionné monsieur le
Président
dans son histoire historique te font le
bundeslak le 27 février il est parlé
d'un changement d'impôts donc site 22
pas seulement pour l'ordre de sécurité
européenne mais aussi pour l'Allemagne
et donc cette discours a enclenché une
vaste réorientation de la politique
sécurité allemande dans des domaines
clés tout d'abord
par la décision de soutenir l'Ukraine en
livrant des armes lourdes pour les
délukraines à défendre sa liberté et son
indépendance et l'Allemagne a ainsi
rompu avec des décennies d'une pratique
qui consistait à ne pas livrer d'armes à
des pays en guerre qui ne sont pas
membres de l'OTAN et l'Union européenne
donc c'était pour nous tout à fait
nouveau inédits même révolutionnaire si
vous si vous voulez et on a un an après
le début de l'agression russe
l'Allemagne et avec la Grande-Bretagne
et derrière les États-Unis la principale
fournisseur dans l'Ukraine
et ça va des chars de combat léopard 2
véhicules de combat d'infanterie
mardères blindé guépard jusqu'au système
de défense anti-arienne pétruite et Iris
T et pour permettre à l'Ukraine
d'acheter un des armes l'Allemagne
apportée aussi une vaste contrebition
sur le plan financier également et
l'Allemagne également pris en charge la
formation sur son territoire du cake
5000 soldats Ukrainiens dans les cadres
de mission de l'Union européenne dans
toutes ces discussions concernant les
livraisons d'armes le gouvernement
allemand a été guidé par trois principes
premièrement soutenir l'Ukraine
deuxièmement à faire en sorte que l'OTAN
ne devienne pas en partie au conflit on
entreprend en guerre et troisièmement
toujours prendre chaque décision on est
trois
concertations avec avec des alliés la
France les États-Unis et les autres
le gouvernement fédéral n'a eu de cesses
rappeler que l'Allemagne soutiendra
l'Ukraine aussi longtemps que nécessaire
dans son combat pour la liberté et cela
s'applique également à l'aide civile
fournit à l'Ukraine et dans ce domaine
également l'Allemagne et le premier pays
donateur derrière les États-Unis
et par son soutien l'Allemagne vise à
aider l'Ukraine dans son combat pour la
liberté mais aussi pour convaincre
Poutine qu'il ne pourrait pas gagner
cette guerre et c'est aussi à cet effet
que le chancelier de temps en temps
parle avec le président Poutine comme
d'ailleurs aussi le président Macron et
je pense que généralement en ce qui
concerne
nos réactions à cette terrible guerre
l'Allemagne et la France sont
parfaitement alignés peut-être quelques
détails sur
en ce qui concerne le soutien
jusqu'à présent en termes de soutien
bilatéral à l'Ukraine l'Allemagne a
dépensé
12,7 milliards d'euros
dans soutien militaire à l'Ukraine après
2,3 milliards d'euros
vous avez mon CV monsieur le Président
des 14 chars léopard
il y a aussi donc les hommes les 14 les
véhicules blindés Menda Marder et 30
chars antérieurs guépards
un premier système de défense
anti-arrhée
et un système de défense antiarienne
le ministre de France allemand monsieur
pistolet s'est rendu à Kiev dans le
contexte de cette visite
on a annoncé que le gouvernement
allemand va donner son accord à
l'exportation de
178 chars léopard 1 à l'Ukraine
c'est-à-dire de la plupart des séchage
se trouve dans les stocks de l'industrie
allemande mais également le Danemark et
les Pays-Bas se sont alignés à cette
déclaration donc ce sera je pense en
autre quand on reçoit très essentielle
pour en ce qui concerne donc les
à l'Ukraine
178 char qui devait être livrés au cours
des des mois des mois qui viennent
un autre il y a donc en montant total
allant jusqu'à 1
7 8 milliards d'euros et mis à la
disposition des forces américainiennes
pour leur sacquisition et on est au
réfugiés donc l'Allemagne a enregistrée
l'arrivée de plus de 1 million du
crinien et d'ukrainienne
sur son territoire et on a soutenu ce
réfugier avec
à la hauteur de 8,2 milliards d'euros
il y a aussi un soutien non militaire
l'Ukraine et des voisins ce sont à peu
près 3 milliards d'euros donc ce sont
des mesures tout à fait essentielles
le deuxième axe du changement d'époque
pour la politique de sécurité amende
concerne la hausse massif du budget de
la défense par les biais vous l'avez
mentionné monsieur le Président de la
création d'enfants particuliers
d'autiste de 100 milliards d'euros et
ses moyens supplémentaires doivent
permettre à la manière de se conformer à
l'avenir à l'objectif de l'OTAN fixé par
le temps à savoir consacrer au moins 2%
du pipe à la défense il s'agit là donc
de donner le plus rapidement possible
à une sphère longtemps sous-financé à
insuffisamment équipé les moyens de
pleinement remplir ses missions dans le
cadre de ton et de l'Union européenne il
est pour cela nécessaire de combler
d'importantes lacunes dans les systèmes
d'armes l'équipement des troupes
de la situation là le gouvernement
fédéral n'a d'autre choix que de
recourir au système disponible sur la
machine c'est-à-dire de
d'acheter ce qui sur l'étagère
enfin
nous avons réagi à l'agression russe
Henri a fait mon vigoureusement nos
engagements au sein d'alliance
conformément à l'article 5 et dans ce
contexte la manière renforcé sa présence
militaire sur le flanc est le temps en
mettant à disposition une brigade pour
la Lituanie en déployant des effectifs
supplémentaires en Slovaquie
d'autres par l'Allemagne assure en 2023
le commandement de la le cadre nation de
la budgetf la Force opérationnelle
internationale
et enfin le gouvernement fédéral a
réaffimon son attachement à la mission
de la dissuasion nucléaire nucléaire de
l'OTAN c'est aussi longtemps que la
Russie disposera dans l'arsenal
nucléaire l'OTAN aura besoin
d'une dissuasion nucléaire crédible et
efficace et l'Allemagne va contribuer au
titre du partage nucléaire à ceux à
cette dissuasion nucléaire de l'OTAN et
à cet effet
le gouvernement allemand
fera l'acquisition de 35
F35 pour remplacer les chasseurs
tornades utilisés dans le cadre de la
dissuasion nucléaire de l'OTAN
en mots sur sur un autre aspect très
important de du tournant historique de
l'Allemagne c'est la politique
énergétique qui joue enrôles aussi dans
le cadre de la politique de sécurité
dans les mois suivant la teinte russe
la manière à décider de mettre en terme
aux relations en matière d'énergie
fossile avec la Russie bon c'était un
défi énorme n'est-ce pas étant donné que
par exemple
au début le 22 encore 55% de la
consommation de gaz
donc venez de la Russie donc c'était
enorme n'est-ce pas de remplacer le gaz
russe mais aussi le charbon et le
pétrole russe dans un délai extrêmement
bref
parmi les principales conclusions que
l'Allemagne a attiré des cyclistes et
dernières années
marqué pas seulement par la guerre mais
aussi par de beaucoup de maintes crises
aussi de la géopolite d'une concurrence
géopolitique croissante c'est le
l'ambition vraiment de renforcer la
souveraineté et de la capacité d'action
de l'Europe et je pense que l'Allemagne
et la France sont 100% d'accord sur cet
objectif et le dernier conseil du
ministre franco-allemand a encore
confirmé cette ambition partagée d'une
manière impressionnante et du point de
vue allemand cet objectif existe des
progrès dans trois domaines
premièrement les reformes
institutionnelles de l'Union européenne
par exemple par la généralisation du
principe du vote à la majorité qualifiée
deuxièmement le renforcement de
l'indépendance économique et
technologique de l'Union Européen
européenne ainsi que de sa compétitivité
c'est toute sa discussion sur la réponse
de l'Europe à
entre autres à l'infraction rédaction à
des États-Unis c'est la raison pour
laquelle
hier le ministre le maire et avec ce
sont rendus à Washington pour discuter
de cette question avec les autorités
américaines et troisièmement c'est le
renforcement de la
capacité d'action militaire de l'Union
de l'Europe et en ce qui concerne ce
dernier point il est clair que la France
et l'Allemagne ont une responsabilité
commune particulière pour renforcer les
capacités des Européens à cette défendre
je pense que la France est l'Allemagne
ça fait donc
ça fait 40% des des budgets de défense
totale de l'Union européenne donc la
France Allemagne joue un rôle tout à
fait essentiel à cet égard
et dans ce domaine l'Allemagne a promu
ces derniers années
d'important projet en étroite coloration
avec la France je mentionnerai dans ce
contexte la coopération en structurée
permanente dans le sens la création du
Fonds européen de défense là boussole
stratégique pour l'orientation future de
la politique de sécurité des forces
communes adoptée sous la présidence
française du conseil et puis donc
l'instauration d'une facilité européenne
pour la paix doté de 5 millions d'euros
et celle-ci a permis à l'Union
européenne d'un pays l'Ukraine à acheter
d'importantes quantités d'armes pendant
la première année de la guerre pour
promouvoir une objet politique
l'Allemagne essentielle de renforcer
donc les capacités militaires
européennes et dans ce contexte et
peut-être on va en discuter plus en état
plus tard les projets font quoi le monde
mgcs de l'eurodrome mais aussi donc
la création d'un escadron de transport
aérien vrai sont des éléments tout à
fait majeurs central
c'est également dans un objectif de
renforcement des capacités militaires de
joueuriens qui s'inscrit l'initiative
allemande
dans le Bouclier anti-arien européen
dans le cadre de l'OTAN qui est ouvert à
tous les partenaires européens de l'OTAN
et dans le même temps l'Union européenne
doit renforcer sa capacité d'action
militaire dans son voisinage immédiat et
la manière fournira donc en important
contingent à la force de réaction rapide
de l'Union européenne pour 2022 et dans
les effets pourront atteindre 5 à 1000
soldats enfin c'est aussi notre vue pour
mener efficacement ces opérations
militaires européennes il est
indispensable de créer une capacité de
planification de commande n'est-ce pas
au sein de l'Union européenne
le président mesdames les signatrices
monsieur le sénateurs je m'arrête ici à
et je lui d'échanger avec vous donc
surtout ces questions mais peut-être
aussi d'autres questions merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de cette
présentation générale sur l'état de
notre coopération et sur la situation en
Europe et donc sans plus attendre je
donne la parole à Joël guerriot
merci président j'étais justement en
train d'écrire la question l'Europe ne
peut plus Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
l'Europe ne peut plus s'offrir le luxe
de la division d'où l'importance d'une
parfaite entente entre notre entre nos
pays et cela pas seulement l'affichant
le 22 janvier 2023 pour fêter
l'anniversaire du traité de les lycée le
29 août 2022 le chancelier Olaf Schulz
avait plaidé dans son discours sur
l'Europe à Prague pour un élargissement
d'Union européenne à 36 états ce que
Paris avait rejeté sous forme préalable
de l'Union européenne
sans réforme péréalade de l'Union
européenne de même certaines décisions
nationales en matière de politique
énergétique et militaire fragilisent la
confiance mutuelle entre l'Allemagne et
la France la tendance de l'Allemagne a
acheté des systèmes d'armes américains
me semble tourner le dos à la capacité
des Européens atteindre leur
souveraineté en matière de défense les
deux gouvernements allemands et Français
peuvent-ils surmonter leur divergence
liées au projet de politique de défense
tels qu'un système de combat aérien
commun et à la restructuration de
l'approvisionnement en énergie je
m'interroge quand dans quelle mesure ces
fissures dans nos relations entre nos
pays profitent aux États-Unis et pire
encore à la Russie merci monsieur
a été attendue alors on va on va faire
honneur au président du groupe d'amitié
France - Allemagne Ronan legleux merci
monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous l'avez
évoqué dans son discours de Prague
effectivement le chancelier Olaf Scholtz
insistait sur le besoin d'opérer un
rattrapage en matière de aérienne en
Europe
il s'agit de construire un système
aérien commun et non une simple
harmonisation des différents systèmes
existants les ministres de la défense de
15 pays alliés se sont réunis à
Bruxelles le 13 octobre 2022 en ce sens
et il se trouve comme vous le savez que
donc la France n'est pas
partie prenante comment selon vous
pouvons-nous justement construire cette
ce système aérien commun avec la France
je vous remercie
merci François Bono
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur
Vladimir Poutine fait une guerre hybride
à l'Occident et particulièrement à
l'Europe et je voudrais vous parler là
des questions énergétiques vous les avez
vous les avez également abordé
sachant que effectivement
le encharissement du gaz à très
fortement perturbé un grand nombre de
pays européens mais avec aussi des
conséquences c'est la corrélation de de
l'électricité et du gaz
qui avec une augmentation très forte de
l'électricité qui qui pénalise
énormément
des secteurs des banquiers des économie
notamment de la France il va y avoir une
réunion fin mars sur la possibilité de
découpler le prix de l'électricité sur
celui du gaz quelle sera la position de
l'Allemagne sur ce point très précis
merci
merci François Patriat merci monsieur le
Président
de l'énergie si je comprends tout à fait
l'importance de la question de François
Bonnot mais le traité d'exploit chapelle
a maintenant trois ans vous savez qu'il
comporte un volet écologique qui prévoit
des projets conjoints pour développer
les énergies renouvelables et favoriser
l'économie l'efficacité énergétique mais
la guerre en Ukraine façonne une
nouvelle géopolitique de l'énergie qui
est propice à une accélération de la
transition énergétique dans ce contexte
selon vous comment pourrait-on accroître
la synergie franco-allemande en matière
de développement des énergies
renouvelables
merci président Jean-Marc des skinny
merci monsieur le président
moi j'irai un peu dans la suite de Joël
Derio j'ai été très attentif au
communiqué publié par l'Elysée le 22
janvier 2023
l'Europe est effectivement confronté à
une guerre
inattendue en Ukraine et les enjeux sont
communs pour
nos deux pays en matière d'énergie en
matière de défense mais y compris en
matière de spatial je reviendrai pas
sous le prix du gaz il a été abordé
moi je constate que le communiqué de
l'Elysée suite à la rencontre entre nos
deux pays et très positif et va
naturellement dans le bon sens mais
qu'en est-il du projet
anti-missiles entre plusieurs pays
européens autour de l'Allemagne dans
l'OTAN s'est félicité mais qui laisse
sur ce sujet là sur ce concept-là la
France complètement isolée c'est quand
même un problème important dans le cadre
d'une Europe de la défense au niveau du
spatial vous l'avez abordé il est abordé
aussi dans dans les échanges
franco-allemands vous développez seul un
projet de port spatial pour des
microlanceurs et jusqu'à maintenant j'ai
plutôt l'impression que vous que
l'Allemagne s'oppose au principe de
préférence européenne
le sommet entre deux pays a été reporté
à trois reprises
est-ce quelque chose qui pourrait
indiquer un problème dans la relation du
couple franco-allemand dont tout le
monde se vante que un moteur puissant
pour le fonctionnement de l'Europe
est-ce tout simplement
l'impression des Français ou est-ce
réellement
un accord qui tient et qui va tenir dans
l'avenir je comprends que en tout cas
les positions de l'Allemagne moi je suis
voisin de l'Allemagne je suis sénateur
de la Moselle je connais l'importance
des relations franco-allemandes et c'est
pour cela que je m'interroge sur ce
c'est communiqué mais sur la réalité à
côté
qui est un peu différente voilà je pense
que l'Europe de la défense est quelque
chose d'important mais cela a été évoqué
le matériel
acheté aux Américains et chaque pays
fait ce qu'il veut il est autonome mais
tout cela
permettra-t-il de d'avancer sur par la
suite sur les accords de défense
européen sur le staff surtout cela ou
est-ce tout simplement des mots que l'on
va utiliser très longtemps pour
finalement aboutir un peu de choses
alors je prends encore un orateur pour
ce premier groupe de questions Jacques
leney oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur votre Ministre de
la Défense a évoqué le fait de rétablir
le service militaire est-ce une idée qui
est actuellement étudiée au sein du
gouvernement et si oui avec quel
calendrier et quel modalité et dans un
tout autre domaine l'Allemagne a encore
vu ça dépendances avec la Chine
s'accentuer cette année qu'elle pisse
sont étudiés pour mettre fin à cette
dépendance a-t-il envisageable pour
Berlin d'étudier cette question au
niveau européen
merci Jacques je suis l'ambassadeur je
vous laisse répondre à ce premier train
de question
oui donc il y a plusieurs sénateurs en
évoqué la question des achats d'armes
américains donc je me suis attendu à
cette question évidemment et bon déjà
essayé d'en mettre une introduction de
brièvement expliqué là donc il y a une
contrainte énorme n'est-ce pas pour
l'Allemagne vraiment de combler donc des
lacunes considérables en ce qui concerne
nos systèmes d'armes et notre équipement
il faut faire ça à court terme donc il y
a vraiment la nécessité de d'acheter ce
qui est sur l'étagère ce qui est
fonctionne qui est disponible et souvent
ce sont
faute d'alternative européenne ce sont
des systèmes américains
et en ce qui concerne donc les fameux
F35 donc nous sont confrontés à la
nécessité vraiment de remplacer dans les
années qui viennent les Tornados par un
avion qui peut assommer donc le rôle
dans le cadre de la dissuasion nucléaire
de l'OTAN et
là donc je pense que lève 35 est
vraiment la viande de combat qui qui
peut
donc
remplir cette fonction
pratiquement il n'y a pas d'alternative
pour le reste donc je dirais que
comme le chancelier a dit donc c'est ces
grands projets font comme monde France
sont pour nous une
priorité stratégique absolue nous savons
que c'est ce projet ne sont pas faciles
donc il y a beaucoup de questions à
régler de les industriels des intérêts
industriels à réconcilier mais quand
même
donc la manière reste engagée dans le
cadre de ces projets car et le
chancelier a parlé à Prague en son
discours sur l'Europe de la nécessité de
créer une Europe géopolitique
c'est-à-dire en Europe qui qui est
capable aussi d'agir militairement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on mise
donc sur ces sur ces projets
franco-allemand européens moi ce sont
des des
projets structurants à long terme
mais il faut beaucoup de patience
vraiment pour une mine à bien c'est ces
projets là donc je vois pas une
contradiction
d'une part entre donc la nécessité de
combler les lacunes à court terme et je
pense que c'est dent à l'aide l'Europe
qu'il y ait une Allemagne et qui soit
capable de d'agir militaire
militairement et de l'autre côté comment
de pas à pas n'est-ce pas renforcer les
capacités les capacités européennes
en ce qui concerne donc le bouclier
aérien donc dans ce discours le
chancelier avait dit donc c'est donc
c'est une initiative car c'est une
licence que nous avons tirée de la de la
guerre en Ukraine donc la défense
aérienne est tout à fait centrale d'où
la nécessité vraiment de renforcer notre
notre défense aérienne là en Allemagne
il y a des mais aussi
dans la plupart des États membres
l'Union européenne de l'OTAN de lacunes
énormes qu'il faut combler donc il faut
encore une fois agir vite et c'est la
raison pour laquelle a fait cette cette
proposition il a dit donc c'est une
initiative tout le monde peut se peut y
participer il y avait deux réunions
après ces discours à Berlin
organisé par le ministère de la France
la France était représentée mais
finalement le Français a pris la
décision de ne pas y participer donc
c'est une décision de la France
mais en ce qui concerne le futur je
pense que là il y a beaucoup encore
beaucoup de de
questions à discuter et je pense que
cette initiative reste ouverte à tous
les tous les des membres européens de
l'OTAN mais nous pensons que c'est
vraiment c'est une proposition
pertinente qui adresse qui aborde en
problème central de la sécurité de tous
les de tous les Européens
en ce qui concerne l'électricité et le
gaz
donc nous sommes confrontés à vraiment à
la nécessité d'une réforme du marché
d'électricité donc la crise la
clairement démontré et dans le
communiqué le Conseil ministre
francophone allemand le français
souligné donc la nécessité de travailler
ensemble en ce qui concerne
le marché d'électricité
je pense qu'en dans deux étapes
dans une première étape il s'agit
d'optimiser donc l'existant marché de
l'électricité et deuxièmement et
deuxièmement donc je pense que la
Commission européenne va mettre sur la
table des propositions pour une pour une
adaptation si vous voulez du marché
d'électricité à long terme mais pour
cela donc il nous faut du temps
c'est à dire en Allemagne on a lancé un
processus
avec avec tous les tous les acteurs dans
le domaine de l'énergie d'électricité
pour discuter donc du futur de du marché
de l'électricité pour nous
principalement donc il y avait des prix
très élevés mais principalement donc le
marché d'électricité a fonctionné aussi
dans la crise car donc il y avait une
crise d'approvisionnement électricité
donc les prix étaient très élevés mais
de l'autre côté il y avait assez
d'électricité et ça à mon avis c'est un
atout le deuxième mois il y a aussi ce
point principe de du Mérite du Mérite
ordre aussi ce principe à notre à notre
vue donc à jouer un rôle très important
et donc puis on verra comment on va
mener cette discussion au cours de cette
année sur la question du de la réforme
du marché d'électricité
en ce qui concerne la coopération
franco-amande en matière de des énergies
renouvelables c'est tout à fait
important je suis tout à fait d'accord
donc il y a ce désaccord très clair sur
le nucléaire donc on va pas changer ça
c'est-à-dire
les Allemands ne vont pas convaincre les
Français d'abandonner le nucléaire et le
français ne vont pas convaincre les
amants donc de rendre de revenir au
nucléaires donc il faut vivre avec ces
différences mais en même temps
travailler comparer sur la question des
solaires développement des énergies
renouvelables et là il y a un nombre des
aspects tout d'abord il faut soutenir
les industries
en matière de renouvelables c'est là
tout l'enjeu de la réponse européenne à
c'est à dire
flexibilité flexibiliser le système des
états par exemple agir beaucoup plus
vite en ce qui concerne les pieds
utiliser le front qui existe à Bruxelles
plan de relance lui parler U pour
soutenir
nos industries en matière des énergies
renouvelables activer aussi la banque
d'investissement européenne
etc là et un dispositif qui est là pour
soutenir les énergies renouvelables et
sur ce point là la France et l'Allemagne
sont tout à fait d'accord aussi en ce
qui concerne le plan qui a été mis sur
la table par la présidente fonda line
la semaine dernière il y a aussi des
concrets très des projets très concrets
je mentionnerai l'hydrogène qui est très
important à une forme d'énergie
renouvelable du futur là il y a par
exemple un projet très important entre
Air Liquide et ziemens en Normandie pour
la pour le développement des incluseurs
la production de l'hydrogène il y a là
en Vasse terrain de coopération qui se
qui se dessine déjà aujourd'hui puis il
y avait la question du spatial en jeu
très important
aussi sur ce point-là
parfois ce sont des discussions
difficiles mais généralement il y a là
encore très clair que le spatial c'est
un enjeu de souveraineté européenne et
le chancelier était très créé à
là-dessus donc pour le pour le pour
l'Allemagne l'accès indépendant de
l'Europe à
l'espace et tout à fait central c'est un
enjeu de souveraineté européenne
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
soutenons l'Allemagne aussi Ariane 6
malheureusement il y avait ce retard en
espérant en ce qui concerne
6 et le premier lancement mais il y a
aucun doute que l'Allemagne
soutient ce projet finance ce projet
et soutien aussi le principe de
préférence européenne en ce qui concerne
l'usage des lanceurs
ça n'inscrit pas que
que on soutien également le
développement des micro lanceurs donc ce
sont un espèce de lanceur qui sont
nécessaires dans le futur
et
on partage cette analyse avec la France
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
dit dans le communiqué du 22 janvier que
quand on soutient aussi le développement
des microlosseurs la France est
également touchée
en programme pour le pour le soutien du
micro lanceur
mais là je ne vois pas en principe
en désaccord faut encore allemand
mais donc il nous faut également aussi
une discussion sur la question comment
gérer d'une manière efficace n'est-ce
pas le progrès Marianne 6 mais c'est une
discussion tout à fait légitime à mon
avis
dernier point la Chine il y avait un
problème de service militaire allemand
aussi
oui donc mais je le vois pas que pour le
moment on y a vraiment une discussion
sérieuse si vous voulez sur le rein
instruction du service militaire
donc pour le moment je vois pas en ce
qui concerne la Chine c'est en gros
sujet de la Chine c'est c'est beaucoup
de choses la Chine c'est un partenaire
économique très important la Chine est
importante qui concerne le changement
climatique de l'autre côté
la Chine est aussi comment dire en rival
systémique mais aussi
en concurrent donc
la Chine a changé c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut adapter notre politique
vis-à-vis la Chine ça c'est tout à fait
essentiel sur ce point-là il y a aussi
un dialogue avec avec la France comment
façonner au futur n'est-ce pas notre
politique
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de la Chine et
il me semble que
une idée comme comme
découplage n'est ce pas vous allez la
Chine c'est pas réaliste car comme j'ai
déjà dit la Chine va jouer un rôle très
important économiquement
également le changement climatique mais
de l'autre côté il nous faut diversifier
nos
relations commerciales économiques
travailler plus avec des partenaires qui
qui partagent nos intérêts nos valeurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle par
exemple le chancelier se rendu récemment
en Asie au Vietnam et il y a deux
semaines en Amérique latine en Brésil
Argentine en Chili vraiment pour
diversifier le spa pour nos relations
commerciales économique sur ce plan-là
il me semble qu'il y a aussi un accord
très profond entre la France et
l'Allemagne mais aussi au sein de
l'Europe
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur on va
prendre le deuxième et dernier train de
question Catherine Dumas
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur votre engagement faveur
des relations franco-allemande et tout à
fait reconnu cependant on a un peu
l'impression que la relation
franco-allemande peut sembler parfois et
aujourd'hui fragiliser plus que jamais
pourtant la France et l'Allemagne
doivent revenir à l'essentiel de leur
responsabilité historique
en démontrant courage et leadership
alors sur ce point je voudrais revenir
sur un propos introductif du président
Cambon à propos du renouveau bilatéral
qui était voulu par l'accord
d'Aix-la-Chapelle qui intègre la
coopération des parlements nationaux le
président Cambon la évoqué je voudrais
savoir quel est votre réflexion sur ces
parlements nationaux ne sont-ils pas
encore trop absents du processus de
décision européen
merci
Olivier cigolotti merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur l'Ambassadeur même si
personne ne peut nier en Europe que
l'amitié franco-allemande à bel et bien
fait ses preuves
l'invasion russe en Ukraine l'envolée de
l'inflation la crise énergétique ont
créé inévitablement des tensions entre
nos deux nations si le déblocage du
dossier SCAF a redonné un peu de tonus à
notre coopération
ça a été évoqué celle-ci a été assombri
par le projet allemand de bouclier
anti-missiles qui a suscité beaucoup
d'incompréhension à Paris nos deux pays
ont des cultures militaires différentes
la France fait
de sa puissance militaire en élément
central de sa politique internationale
et l'Allemagne demeure plus réticente à
s'engager dans cette voie ma question
est la suivante Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
est-ce que nos divergences industriels
et militaires ne sont-elles pas
systématiquement plus fortes que nos
volontés politiques
merci xori
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur régulièrement présenté par
l'Union européenne comme un partenaire
majeur la Turquie entretient des liens
plus particuliers encore avec avec
l'Allemagne monsieur comment cette
relation bilatérale dans ce contexte de
conflit aux enjeux multiples a-t-elle
évolué depuis le 8 décembre 2021 et la
fin des mandats de d'Angela Merkel je
vous remercie merci Gisèle Jourdain
ma question sera très brève Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur parce que vous puisque
vous y avez répondu précédemment elle
portait sur cette dépendance économique
constatée donc en
2022 par rapport donc au commerce et aux
importations chinoises mais vous avez
largement répondu merci Gisèle Ludovic
est merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur chers collègues lors de la
présentation de son plan numérique 2030
le commissaire européen Thierry Breton a
défendu l'idée de doubler la capacité de
production de semis conducteur en Europe
et on s'est pertinemment tous au tour de
cette table que les semi-conducteurs
sont devenus aussi bien dans l'industrie
en général automobile mais aussi dans la
dans l'industrie de défense et
l'industrie de l'armement un lien et un
élément incontournable pour lui c'est
une ambition qui est indispensable au
niveau de l'Europe pour satisfaire les
besoins de demain et notamment répondre
aux différents besoins alors aujourd'hui
on a des des cibles d'implantation et
l'Allemagne en fait partie nous en
sommes très heureux notamment d'une
grosse usine de fond c'est la partie qui
constitue la puce électronique en
elle-même mais on sait pertinemment que
l'industrie du semi-conducteur c'est
aussi beaucoup d'autres usines de
conditionnement de logistique etc
comment comment imaginez-vous la
collaboration avec la France dans le
développement de ces semis conducteurs
monsieur
merci Ludovic Guillaume compta
oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président Monsieur l'Ambassadeur l'Union
européenne et l'Ukraine ont convenu
la mise en place d'un bureau d'enquête
pour recueillir les preuves sur crime
d'agression de la Russie Union
européenne soutient également la
création d'une juridiction compétente
pour ce type de crime mais sa forme on
l'a vu soulève des questions soit un
tribunal international spécial ou une
juridiction hybride relevant du droit
ukrainien a priori l'Ukraine voudrait
justement un tribunal spécial mais j'ai
cru voir que l'Allemagne a fait part de
ses doutes et soutient plutôt un
tribunal hybride je voulais savoir si
vous pouviez nous éclairer sur ces
discussions et sur votre votre
proposition et puis l'avancée de ces
discussions et puis peut-être de manière
générale sur le les discussions sur le
long chemin de l'entrée de l'Ukraine
vers l'Union européenne merci
merci Guillaume enfin vive
merci Monsieur le Ministre enfin vivez
de Lopez
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur merci pour toutes vous
explications vous avez beaucoup parlé
des États-Unis de la Chine mais qu'en
est-il avec l'Inde c'est un pays que
l'on ne parle pas beaucoup et qui porte
un prend une grande importance je vous
remercie
voilà
merci de répondre à l'ensemble de nos
intervenants
bon en ce qui concerne donc les la
première question donc le rôle de
Parlement nationaux
en font comment
je voudrais surveiller encore une fois
donc c'est
cette
la création de l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande donc
les grès du Sénat sont bien connus mais
de toute façon donc je me suis
partiellement impliqué pour intensifier
le dialogue entre donc les commissions
du bundestac et votre commission du
Sénat
ça aurait lieu très bientôt
j'espère
mais en ce qui concerne donc les
affaires européennes je pense qu'il y a
là une en ce qui concerne le bunosta une
retraite
joue un rôle très important en ce qui
concerne la politique européenne du
gouvernement
il y a aussi donc une discussion n'est
ce pas sur le sur le renfoncement du
Parlement européen donc c'est c'est
l'autre piste il y a aussi une
préparation des des
parlements européens nationaux dans les
différents dans le contexte des
différents comités
donc je pense que en ce qui concerne
l'Allemagne et donc il n'y a pas une
en manque n'est-ce pas de des
possibilités pour le pour la pendant
allemand n'est-ce pas de d'influencer la
politique européenne du gouvernement
donc je peux pas parler pour la France
mais en ce qui concerne l'Allemagne ça
me semble
de la vie prépondérante
encore une fois le bouclier antimissile
et les cultures stratégiques
vous avez tout à fait raison
donc c'est nos points de départ en ce
qui concerne les cultures stratégiques
sont très différentes donc là la France
avec une tradition à l'intérieur pour
tradition militaire stratégique pas un
de rompu mais pour l'Allemagne à cause
de l'histoire c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait différent mais l'autre côté
nous sommes dans une situation inédite
et il me semble que
nous avons en Allemagne vraiment une
discussion sur un changement de culture
le chancelier à parler d'un changement
d'époque et ça vaut aussi pour à long
terme je pense que pour la pour la
culture stratégique de
l'amène et c'est la zone par exemple
que nous sommes en train de pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
République fédérale d'Allemagne et de
développer une une stratégie de sécurité
nationale
cette stratégie va être publiée dans les
mois qui viennent et c'est la première
fois que l'Allemagne le gouvernement
allemand va présenter en vue d'ensemble
dans des nos intérêts stratégiques aussi
des des risques ou des défis auxquels
nous faisons face et ça
va servir comme base n'est pas pour un
discours pour une liste ben national qui
qui va qui doit mener à une culture
stratégique adaptée qui est vraiment à
la hauteur à la hauteur de des défis
auxquels nous nous faisons face
bon
de ce point de vue là il me semble que
là aussi le
les crises que nous avons vu aussi la
guerre offre vraiment une opportunité
pour pour une convergence stratégique
entre la France et l'Allemagne à mon
avis c'est un mot
cette guerre c'est un développement
vraiment structurant qui nous offre
aussi des opportunités c'est en grand
défi mais nous offre aussi une
opportunité que le chancelier a parlé à
prendre donc pour la première fois d'une
Europe gyopolitique ça c'est aussi
nouveau donc on n'a jamais parlé
dans le langage politique en Allemagne
de la géopolitique c'était plutôt un mot
problématique pour nous jamais si en
France ou en Grande-Bretagne mais
maintenant donc c'est un discours
vraiment géopolitique à mon avis sur ce
point de de mentalité
d'esprit donc ça ça ouvre une nouvelle
de nouvelle de nouvelles options
bon la Turquie donc c'est
peut-être aussi encore un moment pour
exprimer notre solidarité avec la
Turquie quand c'est dans ces danseurs
très extrêmement difficile pour pour ces
pays la population
torturée par cette terrible séisme
généralement
la Turquie est un partenaire très
important allié très important au sein
au sein de l'OTAN c'est un pays qui qui
herbais-je
presque 4 millions de réfugiés syriens
un pays qui qui se trouve dans un
contexte géopolitique extrêmement
compliqué de l'autre côté donc on a eu
des discussions très difficiles avec la
Turquie sur la question de défense
l'achat des systèmes aériens est-ce 400
russe sur sa position vis-à-vis
dans la
Méditerranée orientale position envers
la Grèce
et
question de politique intérieure et sur
ces questions là je me semble que la
ligne allemande n'a pas changé vraiment
en ce qui depuis
la fin de du gouvernement de Madame
bachel c'est-à-dire donc la Turquie en
partenaire
on a un dialogue franc et aussi exigeant
donc
sur les sur les questions compliquées et
difficiles que j'ai que j'ai évoqué
la question des semi-conducteurs
[Musique]
sur ce point-là
il y a aussi un accord je pense entre
nos deux pays c'est-à-dire on a soutenu
cette initiative de la Commission dans
le cadre du chips ect c'est à dire de
mise à disposition de plus de 40
milliards d'euros pour soutenir le
développement d'une industrie européenne
dans le domaine de semi-conducteurs il y
a des investissements très importants
ici en France mais aussi en Allemagne
par exemple un macbook par Intel il y a
un investissement ditel ici en France il
y a un nouveau investissement
américain je pense en Sart c'est à dire
dans la région transfrontalière
mais sur ce plan là c'est c'est clair
pour pour nos deux pays que l'Europe
doit devenir beaucoup plus indépendantes
en ce qui concerne les semi-conducteurs
pour le moment donc là la dépendance de
l'Europe
sur ce domaine là et
pas soutenable et pas soutenable donc
au cas où il y a eu il y avait par
exemple une crise
en aide au Pacifique je mentionnerai si
le cas du Taïwan donc
nous sommes dans une situation peut-être
très compliqué d'où la nécessité
vraiment de soutenir le développement
d'une industrie forte plus indépendante
européenne dans ce domaine là
et je pense que cette histoire
par le commissaire breton à tous notre
soutien
la question du des crimes des guerres en
Ukraine
certainement donc il doit pas y avoir de
d'impunité
donc les il faut tenir responsable tous
ceux qui sont qui sont responsables pour
ces crimes de guerre et c'est la raison
pour laquelle
la ministre des Affaires étrangères
madame berbock récemment dans un
discours qu'elle a tenu à La Haye à la
Cour internationale se prononcer pour
dans direction premièrement pour la
création d'une
d'un tribunal spécial
international
basé sur le sur le droit ukrainien mais
avec une dimension internationale
c'est-à-dire avec des juges les
procureur internationaux
pour pour vraiment
pour vraiment
mettre un signal très très fort en
espaces on va pas on va pas tolérer donc
c'est crimes de guerre deuxièmement et
se prononcer pour une réforme du statut
de la couronne international car tant
que ce statut ne provoque pas
la question du des
crimes d'agression ça ce sont les deux
positions que nous avons mis sur la
table je pense que la discussion au sein
de l'Union européenne est encore en
cours il y a des
différentes là-dessus ce qui est ce qui
est normal mais ça ce sont des
propositions allemandes en ce qui
concerne la question des crimes les
guerres aussi de la création
tout à fait raison tout le monde parle
de la Chine n'est-ce pas mais il faut il
faut pas jamais sous-estimer l'Inde qui
sera bien très bientôt
le
plus grand de la population le plus
grand pays du monde et ça pose un peu la
question de l'Indopacifique en général
et là il y a une prise de conscience en
Allemagne et que c'est il vous faut
vraiment
attaché beaucoup plus d'importance à
cette région là du point de vue
économique mais aussi stratégique donc
si on parle de l'unopospace public on
peut pas seulement parler de la Chine
mais il faut pas les de l'Inde de
l'autre pays de l'Australie etc
l'Indonésie et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'Allemagne a adopté je pense
qu'il y a deux ans donc des lignes
directrices en ce qui concerne notre
politique en agneau Pacifique
qui sont tout à fait compatibles avec
avec
la politique de la France dans cette
région mais aussi avec la stratégie
européenne en ce qui concerne nos
spécifique et ça veut dire que donc il
faut vraiment
intensifier nos relations avec avec les
pays dans cette région-là sur le point
commercial politique renforcer notre
présence
faire des offres qui sont dans l'intérêt
des CPI là par un simple en ce qui
concerne le la politique commerciale le
changement climatique pour pour
démontrer que dans cette région il n'y a
pas seulement la Chine mais aussi une
alternative il y a aussi l'Europe
n'est-ce pas
ça vaut également pour le pour le pour
l'aspect militaire géostratégique il
faut être réaliste que les moyens
militaires les ressources militaires de
l'Europe sont limités
mais de l'autre côté une fois être
présent et c'est pour laquelle
l'Allemagne a envoyé récemment une
frégate on a nos pacifique
et aussi l'année dernière pour la
première fois c'était en grand
déploiement d'un escadron à Eurofighter
un déploiement pendant 24 heures en
allant au Pacifique c'était dans la
première fois que la boule de suit à la
luftware s'est déployée dans cette
région là et dans le cadre du Conseil
ministre franco-allemand on a décidé
également d'une autre
action
bilatérale militaire dans l'anneau
Pacifique
l'année prochaine si je ne m'abuse donc
sur ce point-là également il y a il y a
il y a un accord profond entre la France
et l'Allemagne disons que donc il faut
il faut
façonner donc notre politique vis-à-vis
la Chine
comme chez les décris mais de l'autre
côté diversifié faire un offre crédible
aussi
aux autres pays de
cette région là et ça s'inscrit dans une
vue qui était souvent décrit par le par
le chancelier qui dit toujours donc le
futur du 20e siècle c'est pas c'est pas
un monde bipolaire c'est pas seulement
les États-Unis la Chine mais ce sera un
monde multipolaire et dans ce cadre là
donc la Chine et les autres pays joue un
rôle très important donc il faut
vraiment prendre
donc l'importance croissante également
de ces pays là il doit se situent se
refléter aussi dans dans notre approche
vis-à-vis la région de la pacifique
merci Monsieur une petite question
complémentaire de l'évier merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur et j'en profite vraiment
pour la
concision et la précision de vos
réponses à chaque fois qui qui faisait
vraiment plaisir je vais essayer d'être
aussi performant que vous très vite
l'Allemagne a fait partie des pays qui
se sont engagés au Sahel militairement
pour contribuer je dirais
à obtenir des solutions
aujourd'hui je serai curieux de
connaître le regard de l'Allemagne sur
la situation au Sahel suite aux
dernières évolutions et de voir quelle
est la presse l'appréciation générale de
la situation
bon la situation est inquiétante
inquiétante tout à fait car donc
l'instabilité
augmente nous avons vu les
développements récents
en Burkina
il y a le problème du Mali il y a le
problème d'une
d'un influence russe croissante
il y a le problème grave qui n'est pas
disparu du terrorisme de la pauvreté les
conséquences du changement climatique
donc c'est un syndrome de des problèmes
pour le moment donc notre
défi de le plus immédiat c'est
certainement la guerre en
Ukraine ou l'agression russe contre
l'Ukraine mais de l'autre côté il ne
faut pas oublier
cette région là parce que c'est le
voisinage de notre voisinage c'est cette
approche donc et il nous faut rester
engagé
l'Allemagne a d'une manière considérable
renforcée sans l'engagement
y compris aussi militaire nous sommes
encore engagés dans le cadre de minusma
jusqu'au printemps 2024
après ça donc il était rasé de terminer
cette la participation
après les élections au Mali c'est-à-dire
on fait ça d'une manière
structurée si vous voulez
mais ce qu'il nous faut vraiment c'est
une approche européenne à cette région
là si vous voulez une stratégie de
l'Union européenne en ce qui concerne
l'Afrique de l'Ouest et ça c'est tout
d'abord bien entendu c'est une c'est le
soutien
calibré dans le domaine de sécurité donc
il faut il faut continuer ce soutien là
par exemple c'est ce qu'on Union
européenne Ferb au Niger c'est important
dans
ces contextes là il faut pas il faut
également aussi
voir ce qu'on peut faire pour les États
côtiers
c'est-à-dire il faut un espèce de
construire à
une zone de stabilité autour du Mali et
autour du Burkina Faso et il nous faut
une stabilise stabilisation civile et
humanitaire ça va de soi ainsi il faut
aider donc ces états en ce qui concerne
la lutte contre les conséquences du
changement climatique ça me semble aussi
tout à fait
important et finalement
améliorer aussi notre communication
stratégique c'est-à-dire
lutter contre cette baisse information
qui est qui est vraiment qui va au
dépenses au détriment de l'Europe et
c'est la raison pour laquelle donc il y
a par exemple la proposition de
d'établir au sein de l'uropéenne une
espèce de tasse force une groupe qui a
une unité qui se vraiment qui qui est
dédié
aux à lutter donc contre la
désinformation pas seulement au sel mais
dans toute l'Afrique car donc l'Union
européenne a joué un rôle en Afrique et
bon ce sont quelques idées n'est-ce pas
mais généralement nous sommes que sur
ces questions là
la coopération franco-mante est aussi
très importante et on est bien entendu
très intéressé à avoir donc les
résultats du
processus qui est en cours qui vise
vraiment à développer une
stratégie nouvelle stratégie de la
France en Afrique de l'Ouest aussi sur
le plan militaire qui a été annoncé par
le président de la République
avant de conclure cette audition je
voudrais revenir sur une question sur
lequel je voudrais avoir plus de
précisions de votre part vous connaissez
bien la Russie comment vous voyez la fin
des choses qu'est-ce qui va arriver à
Poutine comment peut-on en sortir et
quelle solution tout le monde était
interrogé sur ce sujet personne n'a en
vérité de réponse il faut une
connaissance assez précise de
l'intérieur du système russe pour avoir
quelques idées quel est votre sentiment
personnel
bon j'ai
c'est une question assez difficile
n'est-ce pas bon je pense que
généralement ce qui est très difficile
de d'analyser ce qui se passe vraiment
au Kremlin mais de l'autre côté je pense
que ce qui est important pour nous
vraiment de faire en sorte que aussi
parce que nous faisons pour
dire de soutien pour les graines
finalement pour faire en sorte que
les DJ régions russes le président privé
conclut que la Russie ne peut pas gagner
la guerre donc que la continuité
continuation de la guerre fait au
conscience
et ça je pense que ça c'est le premier
pas n'est ce pas qui pourrait donc mener
donc
un certain progrès
mais ne sont pas encore là apparemment
pas du tout à ses pertes
subit par la Méru nous sommes dans une
phase d'une
phase d'escale et
d'où là nécessité vraiment de soutenir
de soutenir l'Ukraine
mais nous mais notre monde sont très
claires la Russie doit cesser ces
sociétés va retirer ces troupes
et
finalement il s'agit de la restauration
de l'indépendance et de la de l'intérêt
d'un territoire territorial de l'Ukraine
mais je pense que ce qui est vraiment
important
que que nous gardions notre unité ça
c'est tout à fait
vital pour nous donc c'était le fameux
carton classe toujours donc le centre de
gravité de chaque ayant c'est l'unité et
donc l'unité c'est tout à fait centrale
l'unité européenne l'unité au sein de
l'OTAN et seulement si nous restons unis
Poutine va finalement conclure qu'il ne
peut pas gagner la guerre
merci merci Monsieur ambassadeur pour
cette audition de fait passionnante je
retiens plusieurs éléments sur lequel
vous avez donné un éclairage tout
d'abord rappeler la nécessité de la
coopération
franco-allemande notamment en matière de
défense nous avons des projets qui ont
subi
un certain nombre d'Avatar mais il
semble que maintenant on soit entré dans
une phase
plus plus favorable plus propice
notamment avec l'accord des industriels
qui étaient absolument nécessaire sur la
partie technique notamment le pilier 1a
du SCAF et donc je pense que ça c'est un
élément important
par ailleurs je veux rappeler que à
l'effort de l'Allemagne en matière de
défense va correspondre les forces
français puisque finalement au 100
milliards annoncés par le chancelier le
président de la République a annoncé un
peu plus de 100 milliards pour la loi de
programmation militaire qui va être qui
va arriver en discussion devant le
Parlement prochainement je pense aussi
que vos
éclaircissements sur la réorientation de
la politique de l'énergie
l'Allemagne est aussi un élément très
important pour aller dans un sens commun
au sens de l'Europe et je partage tout à
fait votre nous partageons tous votre
sentiment sur la nécessité de rester
tous unis pour qu'un jour on retrouve un
dispositif de sécurité en Europe je
voudrais enfin insister sur la nécessité
de la coopération parlementaire entre
nos deux pays je sais ce que vous avez
fait pour que des contacts plus étroits
plus intervenir je veux donc je pense
que nous allons pouvoir rencontrer
Madame stargazimmerman ma collègue la
commission de la défense
d'Allemagne soit Berlin soit ici soit en
tête-à-tête soit avec une petite
délégation
représentative mais je pense que dans la
mesure vous l'avez rappelé le concept de
défense n'a pas toujours été identique
entre la France et l'Allemagne pour des
raisons historiques il est important
qu'on se parle et qu'on se parle souvent
et malheureusement le covid n'a pas
permis d'avoir ses réunions régulières
que nous avions et comme cela a été
rappelé nous souffrons du fait que le
traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle n'a pas prévu
mais c'est aussi le c'est peut-être un
problème plutôt franco-français n'a pas
prévu dans la délégation parlementaire
française la présence des sénateurs ce
qui fait que
alors même que nous avons les mêmes
compétences que l'Assemblée nationale on
a souvent l'occasion d'échanger tous les
deux à ce sujet donc en tous les cas je
serai très volontiers je vous en prie
sur Moser
en ce qui concerne donc la coopération
avec les
les deux
comités du bundestax c'est-à-dire
et défense
il me semble que dans le passé il y
avait aussi donc en format trilatéral
n'est-ce pas
donc je pense que tout à fait
ouvert voilà précédemment avant
justement le traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle il
y avait à son ménage et Sénat j'ai
conduit du reste la dernière délégation
à Berlin avant le covid qui rencontrait
nos amis de la de la de nos collègues de
du bundeslak parallèlement nous avons
évidemment des relations avec le
bundotre puisque le président nouveau a
été reçu ici dernièrement mais je pense
qu'il faut se saisir de toutes les
occasions pour multiplier les rencontres
car encore une fois la répartition
constitutionnelle des pouvoirs en France
en Allemagne est un peu différente il
faut tenir compte de la présence du
Sénat qui en l'occurrence est un pôle de
sagesse et de sérénité dans les temps
que nous connaissons donc faut savoir
utiliser les sénateurs merci infiniment
monsieur ambasser je participerai du
reste moi-même à l'invitation qu'avec
l'ambassadeur de Pologne est adressé
concernant le triangle Weimar donc je
participer à cette rencontre c'est aussi
un autre élément car la Pologne devient
va jouer au coeur de l'Europe un rôle de
plus de plus en plus important vous avez
vu que ces derniers jours la Pologne a
annoncé aussi un très gros effort
d'armement enfin de de renforcement de
son armement donc ce sont des
interlocuteurs dont il faut absolument
tenir compte merci infiniment Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur merci à votre équipe merci
à tout ce que vous faites depuis votre
arrivée je peux ici emporter tes moyens
comme nom d'entre nous pour le
développement de cette relation pour
surmonter parfois les petites
incompréhensions et je pense qu'avec le
groupe d'amitié présidé par notre
excellent collègue dans le bleu qui
siège dans cette commission
tout ceci la présidente qui était là la
présidente de l'Assemblée parlementaire
de l'OTAN qui maintenant siège à la
commission d'affaires étrangères donc
tout ceci est un facteur de renforcement
de nos relations merci infiniment
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci beaucoup
quelques instants